today i'm going to be speaking with joel
lowe who is the ceo of sponsy you can
find out more about
uh the platform at sponsy.sg
as well as
sponsy.io
joel it's great to have you on today
hey yeah likewise dave um i'm happy to
be here david and uh thanks for having
this interview
yeah so let's start a little bit by
talking about the influencer marketing
industry we you know my program
obviously we're very wrapped up in
influencer marketing and the potential
of the industry and how it has developed
uh what do you see as the future and
potential of influencer marketing
yeah so i think influencer marketing um
expands much further than the idea of
marketing itself and i think when we
look forward to the future of influencer
marketing we first have to look
backwards to see how the industry has
evolved and you know what is different
um now versus like in 2016 for example
so i think you know the future of
influencer marketing is to connect uh
micro nano influencers on the ground
level with small and medium-sized
enterprises
i think in the past you know um the
industry has evolved to be one very
dominated by huge players you know names
like logan paul jake paul the emilios um
huge names we've all heard of
but i think that you know there's a huge
untapped opportunity in small businesses
because they're currently not using
influencer shoutouts or sponsorships
and i think as you know as an industry
grows it trickles down the effects of it
trickles down towards the general public
and that is really where sponsy is
headed to create a kind of a new
dimension to this entire industry itself
yeah i i've noticed that you know you
talk about micro and nano influencers
it seems as though
people with following sizes
that maybe 10 years ago would not be
considered big enough to really monetize
your social media presence
you actually can do okay
as long as these are targeted and and
niche and interesting followings you can
actually do okay with a relatively small
following now
yeah i agree um but i think it's also um
you know a very double-edged sword um so
what i mean by that is that um if you
have a small you know number of
followers uh it's incredibly hard to
break into the market as well in some
instances sure so it really depends on
the demographics of the market that
you're in depends from region to region
how large the influencer market is
itself for example in the us and in
australia um the industry is fairly well
developed but you know around the world
we're not seeing the same kind of growth
in influencer marketing um as as in the
us in australia so
yeah i think um there's kind of a
barrier of entry still to to micro and
nano influencers um and yeah so what we
seek to do is kind of level that playing
field and you know make it a fair
opportunity for all
why do you
feel that blockchain technology
can be
implemented or useful
in this entire influencer marketing
ecosystem what what would it do what
does it allow what does it improve
yeah so
very interesting point you you touched
on um so yeah i mean um you know
blockchain is the the hottest thing of
um
um 2021 i guess um and you know we've
seen like um cryptocurrency prices rise
but i think a fundamental thing about
blockchain is that it's not just about
cryptocurrencies there is a whole
network of technologies available for
companies to use um and yeah and that is
something that you know um once we get
adoption
and mass media coverage it's sort of
going out into the into the world right
now and being applied in many different
scenarios so i think um with regards to
the specifics of the technology i would
say that the key thing about blockchain
technology that makes it such an
innovative solution for so many projects
is the concept of decentralization
so i'm not sure if you know all your
viewers are familiar with blockchain
technology but um i think if i were to
sum up what decentralization really
means um it's actually the technological
equivalent of democracy
so it is actually a very interesting
concept because it kind of gives the
authority of regulating a system back to
the individual user
so
so i think when we do it when we do
something you know that involves the
users of a system a lot of things can be
done such as like contracts between
users
you know getting the users involved in
dispute resolution processes so there
are a lot of opportunities when you give
the power back to the user and get the
user themselves to p to be part of an
innovative solution so that's where yeah
no i was going to say along those lines
what's in the sponsi ecosystem that
allows that to happen
right right yeah so um yeah so i think
um we are utilizing blockchain in a
couple of very
niche areas but um they actually solved
the traditional workflow processes we
had problems with in the past so the
first thing is of course digital
resolution so um just imagine this um an
influencer and a business has a dispute
about like payment about deliverables
this this is quite common in the
industry right yeah so
yeah so you know who is to decide um who
is the one who's right here and who is
the one who's wrong especially when
money is involved you know both parties
might not accept you know a third party
solution
but what if what if the general public
or what if the users of the ecosystem
get a say in the decision that's being
made for this dispute itself
so um i think it's a very fair you know
mechanism itself um so yeah and in
spawnc we have something called the jury
protocol so um the jury protocol is
basically just like you know how you
have in the course in the us you have
like a jury based system right so the
members of the public can vote on the
outcome of a system and that is what
sponsee is trying to do and not just
that but we're also leveraging you know
like machine learning models to get the
public to train our model so that it
mimics how a democratic process actually
plays out so that's interesting now how
would that work because so i love the
idea of a dispute resolution system
we've had disputes in our influencer
marketing campaigns and we're basically
figuring it out on our own you know
between the two parties the idea of some
kind of democratization of that sounds
interesting but ultimately am i not just
leaving it up to the opinion of people
that may not really understand my
business in other words what are the
safeguards there with the jury protocol
yeah so the safeguards of the jury
protocol lie in the volume in which we
hope to obtain the jury protocol itself
so yes you're right like if i left the
decision of a dispute up to 10 people it
might not be like a good outcome for
example you know because 10 people is a
small part of the population yeah but
what if you know 10 000 people what if a
million people had a role to play in in
deciding how your model um says what is
right and what is wrong so i guess this
is kind of um ethics-based technology
that we're trying to go for there that's
very interesting i i want to ask about
this is i'm personally interested in
alternative sort of um
work scenarios work weeks and we've been
talking a lot about the four-day work
week and the idea of basically doing as
much work in four days as many
businesses do in the traditional
five-day week at sponsi you guys have a
seven day work week but you also have
unlimited paid leave so can talk about
like how does that work why is that the
system and in practice
what does it lead to what are its
effects
yeah so i would say you know we are not
the the first companies in the world to
to do this system um big tech is is kind
of moving in the in that direction as
well um especially you know like with
with the current pandemic situation
um you know most of us work from home
even though i'm right now in the office
um and yeah and you know we have a large
largely internationally based team you
know half of our team is based in
singapore but half our team is you know
just all around the world from a diverse
you know array of countries like jordan
india
um yeah like many many many countries
basically so
yeah so um how our model kind of works
is that um
we we actually run on a task-based um
system so um in in traditional you know
terminology is called the agile system
um for for programming so what that does
is that we have sprints right we have
periods of like intense work and we we
actually look at the results of of the
of the sprint itself so we don't assign
um into like tasks for people to to
complete we don't dictate you know when
do you start work when you end work i
think everything is task based and task
oriented and we are result oriented as
well so when we do it that way um i
think you know each each person in the
team has kind of an individual
responsibility but at the same time they
kind of get the freedom to work wherever
they want whenever they want as long as
the task is accomplished and as long as
they can communicate with the teammates
to you know kind of set a certain
working environment for each other
do you have a sense of in terms of hours
what the overall impact is accounting
for
task based rather than time based seven
days a week in principle but with
unlimited paid leave
does it sort of work out similarly to
normal jobs i mean what's the actual
impact
yeah so i think the flaw of the like the
five day or four day work week right is
the idea of quantifying work in hours or
in like time yeah um but most of the
time at the workplace you're not
spending all your eight hours you know
at work you're probably spending like
four hours in the toilet or you know
playing playing games on your phone and
stuff like that yeah so um i would say
you know the total amount of work being
done actually increases but the total
amount of productivity also increases
but the time maybe is what goes down
yes the the total time goes down that's
very interesting
last thing on this how long have you
been working in this paradigm
right so um in the
uh you know the defeat of influencer
marketing we started the sponsy project
last year in in 2020
but it was always an idea that um you
know
my fellow co-founders ruben and i had uh
we shared this vision you know since
2016 because we were utilizing
influencer marketing back then already
for a few of our other startups so i
think this is our largest project to
date um and you know it is also our most
promising and you know there's a there's
a long way to go and there's a lot of
opportunities available for us um so
yeah um this this is kind of the the
background of of everything that has has
been going on i guess
where is sponsy headed in terms of the
rest of this year what's what's the end
game what's the sort of big picture of
the road map
yeah so um if you you don't already know
um you can actually download the sponsor
app right now so um yeah it's actually
available on both app store and um
google play
we kind of did a a release of the um
last week just couple of days ago and
we're running a marketing campaign in
singapore right now and the theme of our
marketing campaign centers around
supporting local businesses because you
know there is like a pandemic situation
going on so a lot of small and
medium-sized businesses kind of lose out
to the larger tech corporations so what
we're trying to do is to kind of use
influencer marketing to give these other
businesses a boost um so yeah and in the
long run um you know this the spawn
project is not just about spawn c uh we
actually are planning and developing a
whole ecosystem of projects and
platforms so um we do have another you
know influencer platform for crypto
based influencers coming up it's called
chile
and we also have an nft marketplace that
is also in development right now so i
would say that the whole spawn project
itself um you know it's it's um it it
kind of encompasses a large array of
ecosystem projects
other than specifically
the influencer monetization and dispute
resolution i know you say there's a lot
of different projects can you talk about
some of the specific
uh
services or technologies that the
platform will make available for
influencers
yeah so this is about the sponsy
platform itself right yeah
yeah so um yeah so a couple of things we
are trying to do so i think the first
thing we want to say is that you know we
are not against um talent management
agencies or influencer agencies i think
they do play a huge role
and they have played a huge role in
bringing influencer marketing to the
masses so yeah they're not competitors
and we're actually trying to you know
get them to be our customers as well um
so we're developing our own backend
system that will allow like talent
agencies to manage all of their talents
and models or influences at once via a
single interface so they can chat with
you know all sorts of sponsors from a
single user interface itself um
we're also seeking to do an
international launch very very soon so
the purpose of the singapore launch is
basically you know firstly this is
tribute to our home country because both
rupert and i were from singapore and are
from singapore um yeah and um you know
the second thing is you know it kind of
gives us um
some some market um
market data to to improve our app before
we roll our international launch so i
think um in the in the long run what
features of this ponzi project uh will
you know shine through internationally
is of course um the the idea of the
contract between the influencer or what
we call the spawn c and the business
which is what we call the sponsor and
ultimately uh where we're going is that
we are not trying to label the users of
our apps as influencers we are trying to
create a new field of users called spawn
sees now a spawn c can be anyone you
know who who takes like who who gets
paid to do a sponsorship or a shout out
so that does not restrict you to just
influencers then right because
influencers are very much based on like
social media post of products and stuff
like that as you have the impression of
sure what we're trying to go for yeah
it's like creators for example like
youtube creators i mean you are a very
very successful creator yourself um and
you know um
not just creators but the everyday
person you know who can do like referral
marketing marketing through like family
chat groups and stuff like that now
imagine how cool it will be if you know
you have a family like chat group on or
like whatsapp for example in singapore
right and um you know you got paid like
five dollars just to talk about a
product to your family members i think
it'd be pretty cool because you get very
like you get a very organic outreach and
the method of delivery itself is also
you know very genuine and
organic versus something like uh just a
just a paid shoutout which might come
off as a bit of a cold and uninviting um
kind of shout out so
yeah so um there's a lot of things in
development for this ponzi uh project
itself but that's the direction in which
we are headed yeah people can learn more
at sponsy.sg
as well as
sponsy.io that's with two e's s p
s-p-o-n-s-e-e we've been speaking with
joel lowe who is the ceo of sponsy joel
i really appreciate your time and you
talking to us today
yeah thank you so much david